the government dramatically ramped up
measures on social distancing because we
were on course for a catastrophic
epidemic computer models showed the
impact on critical care units was likely
to be twice as severe as originally been
anticipated and it wasn't just the
elderly as we know younger people have a
much lower fatality rate just eight in
every 10,000 infected thirtysomethings
died but according to Imperial College
scientists significant numbers do need
medical care 320 in every 10,000
30-somethings with symptoms are admitted
to hospital and of those 16 need
critical care if we were able to
mitigate essentially the size of the
epidemic so shift down the peak
sufficiently to an acceptable level then
that would have resulted in a peak
occurring in in a couple of months time
it's clear to us now with the new
information that's coming through
particularly around the severity of the
disease and the requirements for
intensive care units though that's not
really a feasible option and therefore
we're trying to reduce transmission
further and to very low levels so this
is where we would have been heading if
the government had stuck to its policy
of simply isolating people with
coronavirus symptoms at home demand for
critical care beds would have far
outstripped even the surge capacity of
the NHS as soon as mid-april now look
what happens with a new strategy that
adds in household quarantine and
significant social distancing but this
is for five months not the three that
the government has so far announced a
demand hovers around the number of
available critical care beds through the
spring and autumn but surely after
lifting the restrictions cases rebound
because so few people have been exposed
to the virus and developed immunity now
that suggests the restrictions on
contact with other people will have to
last until a vaccine is available and
that could be in 18 months time but
perhaps there is a compromise the social
distancing could be throttled up and
down depending on the pressure on the
NHS it would work something like this
bring in strict social distancing and
the demand for beds quickly drops
is the restrictions so people can resume
normal life and the demand for hospital
care would rise it would according to
the model potentially save lives and in
small windows allow for fun and lifts
the economy but no public health
intervention with such disruptive effect
on society has ever been attempted for
so long and the scientists warn it will
only work if people make an enormous
social sacrifice